wir schauen zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es wieder um
einen gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
zur änderung des zweiten buches
sozialgesetzbuch
und
einfacher wird es sein wenn ich sage es
geht um die sanktionen bei dem
arbeitslosengeld 2 also bei hartz4 die
bundesregierung möchte ich mir eine
übergangslösung erst einmal einführen
das nämlich bis zum jahresende 2022 die
sanktionen ausgesetzt werden
und dann soll ein bürgergeld eingeführt
werden aber bis dieses bürgergeld
eingeführt wird sollen ist ein mal eben
es keine sanktionen geben das verspricht
jetzt als erstes anette kramer liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
krisen management steht aktuell im fokus
der politik doch krise darf nicht
stillstand bedeuten diese koalition ist
angetreten für mehr fortschritt in
diesem land und für uns heißt das auch
wir wollen mehr sozialen fortschritt
erreichen und ein zentrales vorhaben
dabei ist die einführung des bürgergelds
mit dem bürgergeld wollen wir einen
paradigmenwechsel in der grundsicherung
rücken da die menschen und ihre
potenziale der klar in den mittelpunkt
durch einen vorrang von weiterbildung
von einem besseren eingliederung des
prozess und in dem wir den menschen mehr
sicherheit geben wer die grundsicherung
braucht kann sich sicher sein zwei jahre
lang sind die wohnung und das ersparte
geschützt die menschen sollen sich auf
arbeitssuche und qualifizierung
konzentrieren können und dass liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sind nur einige
der punkte die wir im rahmen des
bürgergelds umsetzen wollen
das ist eine komplexe reformen die wir
nicht auf einen schlag umsetzen sondern
verteilt auf verschiedene etappen und
ein wichtiger verdammt vorbereitungs
schritt ist das sogenannte
sanktionsmoratorium über das wir heute
diskutieren wir wollen damit sanktionen
in der grundsicherung für
arbeitssuchende
befristet aussetzen
das gilt bei pflichtverletzung wenn also
beispielsweise
arbeitsangebote abgelehnt oder
weiterbildungsmaßnahmen abgebrochen
werden wer aber ohne wichtigen grund
nicht zu termin im jobcenter er sein
muss wie bisher auch damit rechnen dass
er weniger leistungen bekommt denn eins
ist klar ohne ein gespräch mit dem
mitarbeiter des jobcenter kann es keine
vermittlung in den job geben dass die
persönlichen gespräch mit den menschen
in den jobcentern ist unerlässlich für
eine gute beratung und integration
klar ist mit wirkung im eingliederungs
prozess ist für die allermeisten
menschen absolut selbstverständlich
unsere erfahrungen zeigen letztlich sind
es nur sehr wenige die sich hier
verweigern das werden wir beim
bürgergeld berücksichtigen die
ausgestaltung des moratoriums ist aber
keine vorfestlegung für das bürgergeld
mitwirkungspflichten wird es künftig
weiter geben das haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart das entspricht auch den
vorgaben des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
vom november 2009 10 aber wir werden
aufpassen dass wir nicht über das ziel
hinausschießen das zauberwort heißt hier
verhältnismäßigkeit liebe kolleginnen
und kolleginnen so viel vertrauen wie
möglich soviel verbindlichkeit wie nötig
das wird unser anspruch sein beim
bürgergeld und der sanktionsmoratorium
ist dafür ein erster schritt von
insgesamt 33 sich maßnahmen die uns
dieser koalitionsvertrag auferlegt ich
bitte um ihre unterstützung vielen
herzlichen dank
am ende kann man war das hat hier noch
einmal gesagt es geht um die
verhältnismäßigkeit auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat nämlich
2009/10 geurteilt dass kürzungen um mehr
als 30 prozent nicht verhältnismäßig
wären die ja manche hartz 4 beziehen und
bezieher hinnehmen sollten wenn sie zum
beispiel termine verpasst haben twitter
kann spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen es geschehen noch zeichen und
wunder hier im plenum denn vor zwei
wochen habe ich exakt an dieser stelle
kritisiert dass sie noch nicht einmal
ihr so einfach ins gesetz eine
sanktionsmoratorium es bisher vorgelegt
habe und man schon die befürchtung haben
musste dass das jahr schneller vorbei
sein wird also dass mit diesem gesetz
hier um die ecke kommen aber
offensichtlich hat die kritik wirkung
gezeigt und sie erleben heute ihr gesetz
vor es war ein seltsames pflaster was du
da vorlegen und ich möchte dass am
dreipunkte mal kritisieren sie haben
gerade ihm gesagt dass
oder man muss anders anfangen es gibt
einmal die meldeversäumnisse dass
denjenigen die nicht zum termin
erscheinen und dann gibt es die
pflichtverletzungen das sind diejenigen
die sich hartnäckig verweigern zb eine
zumutbare arbeit zu machen und was sie
jetzt mit diesem gesetz machen ist dass
die meldeversäumnisse weiterhin
sanktioniert werden aber die
pflichtverletzungen nicht mehr auf
deutsch die kleinen die hängen sie und
die großen die lassen sie laufen
verstehe wer will
ich weiß nicht wie sie das eine alte
kassiererin erklären die hart arbeitet
sauer ihr geld verdient steuern zahlt
und mit diesem steuergeld solche
menschen auch noch subventioniert werden
die sich hartnäckig dass die lage
mannschaft verweigern wir halten das für
falsch
es zerstört das vertrauen in den
sozialstaat und ganz ehrlich da verstehe
ich auch die grünlich jahr muss acht
jahre lang hier mit zusammen mit den
linken zum teil immer wieder gesagt
sanktionen das ist drangsalieren und
jetzt aber ja da klatschen sie sogar
noch aber sie beschließen hier ein
gesetz muss ja nicht die sanktion
komplett abschaffen sondern wie wir
lassen ja 80 prozent der sanktionen
werde beibehalten weil 80 prozent der
sanktion auf die auf die
meldeversäumnisse jahr entfallen und da
frage ich sie schon ja was gilt denn
jetzt sind sanktionen schlecht oder sind
sie nicht schlecht wenn sie schlecht
sind dann hätten sie sie komplett
abschaffen müssen das tun sie
offensichtlich nicht zu verheddern sie
da in widersprüche liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von den grünen und dass sie
vielleicht auf die opposition nicht
hören wollen ist nachvollziehbar zwar
unverständlich aber vielleicht
nachvollziehbar aber dann hören sie doch
wenigstens auf dem chef der
bundesagentur für arbeit der wiederholt
gesagt hat dass sanktionen notwendig
sind um mit den menschen in kontakt zu
bleiben verweigern sie sich doch nicht
den expertinnen und experten der
bundesagentur für arbeit
und dann ist er noch ein kleines detail
wirklich spannend weil sie bisher
eigentlich dieses gesetz nur bis zum
31.12 begrenzen wollen weil sie aus dem
osten ersten das bürgergeld einführen
jetzt reden sie davon dass dieses gesetz
zwölf monate dauern soll ab dem
zeitpunkt wo es eingeführt wird
offensichtlich brauchen sie also doch
etwas mehr zeit um ihre mega reform
bürgergeld einzuführen und das zeigt
dass sie sich verzetteln heillos
verzetteln und da muss man schon sagen
warum ist das so wir finden sie
beschäftigen sich mit dem thema
sanktionen viel zu stark weil es
eigentlich nur drei prozent wirklich nur
drei von 100 leuten im sgb ii zwar
wirklich betrifft das ist eine absolute
minderheit die wirklichen probleme und
die gehen sie nicht an sanktionen sind
keine drang sanierer reis alltag unserem
leben wenn der schüler seine
hausaufgaben nicht macht dann gibts
drauf arbeit wenn der arbeitnehmer nicht
zur arbeit punkt dann gibt es eine ab
bis hin zum gehaltsverzicht wenn sie
falsch parken müssen den strafzettel
bezahlen warum soll ich dann auf einmal
eine zwangs sein wenn ein arbeitsloser
seinen pflichten nicht nachkommt das
werden wir ihr nicht durchgehen lassen
kümmern sie sich um die bahn probleme da
geht es um suchtproblemen finanzielle
probleme da geht es um familiäre
probleme
da wären das geld besser eingesetzt
zusammen mit den kommunen herzlichen
dank
twitter können sich hier eine andere
problemstellung in
bezug auf die leistungen von hartz4
natürlich ist auch immer die frage der
höhe wird auch immer wieder
diskutiert
auch die grünen haben ursprünglich einen
höheren bezug gefordert von mindestens
600 euro im monat davon dass jetzt erst
mal nicht mehr die rede andreas outfit
spricht jetzt für die grünen
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
die bundesrepublik deutschland ist ein
demokratischer und sozialer bundesstaat
das sind die maßgaben aus dem park auf
dem artikel 1 und dem artikel 20 des
grundgesetzes
und diese artikel leiten das was wir
hier im bundestag tun und dass die
leighton vor allem auch das was wir in
der sozialpolitik tun und warum warum
erzähle ich das warum erzähle ich ihnen
das ich möchte ihnen erzählen warum wir
grüne ein ganz grundlegendes problem mit
sanktionen in den existenzsichernden
sozialleistungen haben jede einzelne
sanktion jeder einzelne der sanktion ist
ein eingriff in individuelle grundrechte
jede einzelne ausgesprochene sanktion
bedeutet eine kürzung in das
existenzminimum von menschen und wir als
grüne tun uns damit ausgesprochen schwer
das war unsere haltung und das bleibt
unser halten
lassen sie mich die plastisch machen
lassen sich nicht klassisch machen 150
euro haben menschen in der
grundsicherung für nahrungsmittel und
getränke das sind fünf euro am tag fünf
euro für drei mahlzeiten und jetzt
ziehen sie 30 prozent davon ab dann
haben sie noch drei euro fünfzig am tag
um sich zu ernähren für drei mahlzeiten
das ist schlicht und ergreifend zu wenig
es gibt einen zweiten grund warum wir
sanktionen äußerst kritisch sehen wir
wollen dass menschen die chance kriegen
in den arbeitsmarkt einzusteigen wir
wollen dass menschen chancen nutzen
können und an der stelle sind sanktionen
nicht hilfreich in ganz vielen stellen
und das thw das institut für
arbeitsmarkt und berufsforschung hat
selber festgestellt dass menschen durch
sanktionen vor allem in prekäre
beschäftigung gedrängt werden dass es
nicht darum geht an der stelle menschen
in langfristige beschäftigung zu bringen
und das ist ein weiterer grund warum wir
sagen gerade in zeiten in denen es um
arbeitskräftemangel gibt ihr geht in
deutschland müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
menschen langfristig in jobs kommen
langfristig eine gute jobs kommen das
hängt nicht mit sanktionen zusammen
sondern das hängt damit zusammen dass
man menschen chancen gibt und mit ihnen
daran arbeitet tackle glauben sie ein
eps zwischen tage verteilte kann
wir haben das sanktionsmoratorium
vorliegen dass wir heute beschließen und
das ist eine erste etappe auf dem weg
des neuen bürgergeldes das hat die
staatssekretärin
hier dargestellt zwölf monate lang wird
es nun für die meisten menschen keine
sanktionen mehr geben lediglich bei
mehrfachen termin versäumnissen kann
können noch sanktionen bis zur höhe von
10%
angewandt werden das ist die möglichkeit
erfahrungen zu sammeln
und ich bin mir sehr sicher dass in
diesen zwölf monaten die erfahrungen die
wir sammeln werden für viele menschen
überraschend positiv sein soll werden
und genau diese zwölf monate so zu
nutzen dass sollten wir tun
gleichzeitig und das ist das
gesamtkonzept in dem wir arbeiten und so
ist es im koalitionsvertrag angelegt
gleichzeitig haben wir an dreischritt
wir setzen jetzt die sanktionen aus wir
evaluieren was da ist und dann regeln
wir neu das ist die systematik in der
wir arbeiten und dass es diese
systematik die sinn macht und da an
dieser stelle ist völlig klar es wird
mitwirkungspflichten geben
selbstverständlich und diese
mitwirkungspflichten die werden auch zu
sanktionen führen so ist das so ist der
kompromiss wir grüne kam dann kompromiss
gemacht wir hätten das gerne auch anders
geregelt aber so ist das in einer
demokratie so ist das in einer koalition
und selbstverständlich stehen wir zu
genau diesem kompromiss aber das
bürgergeld wird einen anderen geist
haben das bürgergeld wird so aufgebaut
sein dass wir sanktionen nicht isoliert
betrachten sondern das reh sanktionen
gemeinsam betrachten mit anderen
maßnahmen mit der möglichkeit dinge
auszugleichen mit einem mix aus
maßnahmen mit der möglichkeit leuten
auch die chance geben aus sanktionen
wieder rauszukommen es wird viel stärker
um kooperationen gehen als um
konfrontation und wir werden
grundlegende strukturreformen auf den
weg bringen die diese sanktionen rahmen
werden und so insofern einen völlig
neuen fokus setzen den wir mit dem
bürgergeld machen und nicht mehr den
fokus auf die sanktionen wie das bislang
der fall gewesen ist
ich komme zum schluss
wir beraten das bürgergeld jetzt wir
sind auf gutem weg und wir werden eine
neue reform in der ampel vorliegen und
wir sind sicher dass wir das gemeinsam
auf einen guten weg bringen dankeschön
sagt andreas auto ranch der im ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales besitzt wie auch
der nächste redner norbert kleinwächter
für die afg fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen werter kollege
outfit so was die koalition wirklich
vorhat das haben sie ja gestern an
dieser stelle an diesem punkt wörtlich
ausgesprochen wir ermöglichen millionen
von menschen wenn sie zu uns kommen die
möglichkeit ganz direkt in unsere
sozialsysteme zu kommen das haben sie
gesagt und wenn ehrlich gesagt die
bundesregierung das als selbst auftrag
versteht dann kann ich auch durchaus
nachvollziehen warum sie sämtliche
schutzmechanismen unserer sozial
leistungssystem
aushebelt die ukraine kommen direkt in
hartz iv die vermögensprüfung ist ja
ausgesetzt programme hat erwähnt und
jetzt geht es eben auch den sanktionen
nach verstößen an den kragen das
bedeutet ganz konkret nach ihren
vorstellungen dass ein
leistungsempfänger der beispielsweise
eine geeignete stelle ablehnt dann
passiert genau nichts wenn ein
bildungsangebot ablehnt da passiert ihm
nichts wenn er vermögen bewusst beiseite
legt unverschleiert dann passiert ihm
nichts und ich muss ihnen ganz offen
sagen ich finde es nicht in ordnung wenn
in diesem fall nichts passieren das ist
nicht in ordnung
und wenn ich mir dann anschauen das wenn
er einen termin verschläft
meldeversäumnisse eine zehnprozentige
sanktion auf seinem hartz 4 kommt dann
frau habe muss ich ihnen ganz ordentlich
sagen dann habt hat ihnen bei der
gesetzgebung ein bisschen das maß
verzogen das ist nicht in ordnung
die kolleginnen und kollegen
unser sozialsystem ist für die
bedürftigen menschen da und das ist auch
gut so und richtig so und ein großteil
der sozialleistungsempfänger die machen
das bei gott nicht aus spaß sie sind auf
die hilfe des staates angewiesen und
deswegen haben wir auch eine
verpflichtung diesen menschen gegenüber
nämlich die verpflichtung unsere
sozialleistungen systeme langfristig
tragfähig zu erhalten das ist der
auftrag an uns
und wenn wir über sanktionen sprechen
dann müssen wir natürlich auch erwähnen
dass die sanktionen wie sie bisher
existiert haben oft auch ungerecht waren
gerade den bedürftigen menschen
gegenüber da wurden sind ihnen stellen
angeboten die ganzen interessant waren
da wurden ihnen bildungsangebote
unterbreitet die völlig unnütz waren
wenn sie gesagt haben nein das bringt
mir nichts dann wurden sie sanktioniert
das ist das ergebnis der agenda 2010 von
schröder gewesen von rot grün gewesen
und das war falsch und das müssen wir
korrigieren
aber im umkehrschluss zu sagen wir
streichen jetzt mal alle sanktionen
wir sagen es ist uns egal ob du dich
bewegst es ist uns egal ob du auf die
steuerzahler auf der tasche liegt das
gefährdet nicht nur die tragfähigkeit
unserer sozialsysteme werte kolleginnen
und kollegen das ist auch ein hohn das
ist ein hohen all denen gegenüber die
jeden tag in der früh um fünf aufstehen
zur arbeit gehen ja am abend todmüde
heimkommen und dann ende des monats auf
dem gehaltszettel weil sie so hohe
steuern zahlen müssen kaum mehr haben
als derjenige der sozialleistungen
bezieht und sich dann natürlich bei der
sanktions freiheit ganz offen die frage
stellt warum mache ich das eigentlich
und es ist auch ein hohen denen
gegenüber die jeden tag in der früh um
fünf gerne aufstehen würden die gerne
zur arbeit gehen würden den bedürftigen
menschen gegenüber die die die aus
irgendwelchen umständen weil sie keine
stelle finden oder aus anderen umständen
das nicht können das ist auch ein hohen
denen gegenüber werte kolleginnen von
den grünen weil sie nämlich im volksmund
dann in einen sack gepackt werden die
bedürftigen mit denen die das offen
sagen ob ich kriege keine sanktionen ich
bleibe jetzt mal auf meiner couch und
pfiffe und das meine damen und herren
das ist ein hohes in bedürftigen
menschen gegenüber wenn das passiert das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns nicht
aufgetragen alle sanktionen auszusetzen
oder abzuschaffen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat uns an die
verhältnismäßigkeit erinnert das
bedeutet dass sanktionen verhältnismäßig
mit dem pflichtverletzungen sein müssen
übrigens kann eine ablehnung des jobs
auch eine komplette kürzung bedeuten und
deswegen sagen wir ganz offen meine
damen und herren wenn sie millionen
menschen ins land holen wollen herr
outfit dann ist das der falsche weg
unsere sozialen sicherungssysteme haben
nicht die ressourcen haben nicht die
kraft für ihre ideologie haben sie
herzlichen dank
norbert klein recht heft die fraktion
hat hier seine sorgen
formuliert wenn es weniger sanktionen
ergibt das bürgergeld will die ampel
koalition einführen es gibt vorher noch
eine kurzintervention von andrea und
andreas auftritt
herzlichen dank so jetzt habe ich das
mikro vielen dank was wir gerade gesehen
haben ist ein muster was wir vonseiten
der afc immer wieder sehen zum einen das
ewige vermischen von themen und egal
über was man spricht es wird immer hass
und hetze gegen die flüchtete ausgepackt
jedes mal und auch heute wieder und der
zweite teil ist und der zweite teil den
sie den sie ausbreiten ist jedes mal
eine erstaunliche fakten freiheit wenn
man sich wenn man sich anschaut was wir
machen dann ist es die situation
behandeln in der ganz viele menschen dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz sind und
keine chance haben da raus zu kommen
weil es kein prozess gibt und das was
wir jetzt tun ist ihnen das
sozialgesetzbuch 2 und das
sozialgesetzbuch 12 zu öffnen weil sie
dann die möglichkeit haben in den
arbeitsmarkt einzusteigen weil sie dann
die möglichkeit haben unterstützung zu
bekommen schulungen zu bekommen
weiterbildung zu bekommen und das ziel
an dieser sache dass die menschen die
jetzt hier sind teil unseres
arbeitsmarktes werden und gehen sie mal
darauf schauen sie mal bei den kleinen
betrieben die brauchen alle fachkräfte
und wir haben fachkräfte hier wir haben
fachkräfte die aus der ukraine gekommen
sind hier und wir wollen dass die teil
dieser gesellschaft werden dass die
teilhaber hier in dieser gesellschaft
haben und uns weiterbringen mit ihren
kenntnissen mit allem was es dazu gibt
im moment sind es noch einige
hunderttausend aber auch wenn das eine
million werden ist es der bessere weg
menschen eine perspektive zu geben das
ist der bessere weg menschen in die
gesellschaft zu integrieren sind den
arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren und wir
werden alle wir werden davon profitieren
das ist die logik die sie nicht
verstanden haben und deswegen fangen sie
immer wieder an die das pferd von hinten
aufzuzäumen dankeschön
der kleinen richterbund reagieren
selbstverständlich gerne wird
heraustritt dass er ca
aber es gibt ja eine gewisse dissonanz
wenn sie sagen sie möchten
beispielsweise ukrainische flüchtlinge
in den arbeitsmarkt integrieren und das
erste was sie tun ist in
sozialgesetzbuch zwei zu integrieren in
sozialleistungsbezug zu integrieren und
wissen sie wir haben ja erst gestern
darüber debattiert in einer doch
umfangreichen debatte gerät hat für
unsere fraktion hier gesprochen und da
muss man auch ganz offen darstellen das
ist doch eine häufung die passiert also
gestern wurde diese sgb 2 integration
debattiert kräuter geht es um die
sanktionen es gibt auch eine aussetzung
der vermögensprüfung das bedeutet ganz
praktisch ausgedrückt dass jeder auch
wenn er vermögen hat es sein es ist so
groß dass es jedem sofort auffällt dann
ist das ja nicht unbedingt möglich dass
jeder der vermögen hat sogar in unsere
sozialsysteme bekommen kann das sind
offene türen für alle und ich sage ihnen
ganz offen das haben unsere deutschen
steuerzahler nicht verdient das haben
unsere arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer nicht verdient wie jeden
tag arbeit gehen und die das an steuern
abgezogen bekommt jeden monat mehr
erzählt sogar die gez noch erhöhen wegen
inflation da bleibt nichts mehr übrig
und deswegen haben wir eine
verantwortung unseren arbeitnehmern
gegenüber an aller erster stelle denn
die erwirtschaften das alles dann haben
wir eine verantwortung gegenüber unseren
mitbürgern die bedürftig sind und dann
haben wir eine humanitäre verantwortung
die in wirklichen flüchtlingen gegenüber
und gerne autos setzen wir uns darüber
zusammen wie wir die optimalen den
arbeitsmarkt aufnehmen können während
sie flüchtlinge sind auf der flucht vor
diesem grauenhaften krieg herzlichen
dank
wir fahren fort in der debatte und jetzt
erhält das wort für die fdp-fraktion der
politik
folgten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegen muss kollegen vielen dank sie
haben ja mit ihrer antwort auch noch
einmal bewiesen was der kollege
ausgesagt hatten nämlich dass sie mit
absoluter fakten freiheit dinge in den
raum werfen die nicht stimmen wieso
kommen die ukrainischen geflüchtet dann
ins es gebe zwar weil sie dann von den
jobcentern gefördert werden weil sie
dann die aktive arbeitsmarktförderung
bekommen weil sie dann spur
hochspezifische straff förderkurse
bekommt und bald an die kommunen nicht
überbelastet werden weil die
lastenverteilung im sgb 2 einer anderes
als beim asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
informieren sie sich bevor sie ihre
populistischen thesen hier einfach in
den raum stellen
und jetzt zum thema weil sie sprechen
dann jetzt auch in der hetze gegen
ukrainische geflüchtet habe hier geht es
ja um etwas anderes bei dieser debatte
geht es eigentlich um das grundprinzip
von
fördern und fordern
das ist das grundprinzip des
sozialstaates was ja auch die cdu war
weiterhin anerkennt und wenn wir dabei
sind das lüner guide zu reformieren dann
sind wir dabei das bürgergeld auf die
herausforderungen der zeit ob
aufzustellen weil sich seit der agenda
reformen auch die entwicklungen die
notwendig sind verändert haben und
deswegen und das wurde von der
staatssekretärin ja schon gesagt den wir
auch zum ersten ersten die an die axel
das grundprinzip des förderns weil wir
den einzelnen mit einem
weiterbildungsgeld mit 150 euro
unterstützen wollen weil wir in
ausbildung und weiterbildung statt in
aushilfsjobs vermitteln wollen indem wir
den vermittlungs vorwagen abschaffen und
weil wir anreize für hinzuverdienst
setzte das ist die achse des förderns
bald die situation der
langzeitarbeitslosen ist dass zwei
drittel der langzeitarbeitslosen
gar keine berufliche ausbildung haben
weil wir wissen dass sie in den
arbeitsmarkt erst reinkommen wenn wir
sie qualifizieren und da setzen wir den
schwerpunkt beim fördern und bei den
sanktionen da sind wir bald fordern dass
einzelne hin zu fordern aber ihn nicht
zu überfordern und der allergrößte teil
wird auch nicht überfordert das wurde
schon mehrmals gesagt 97 prozent der
bezieherinnen von sgb 2 leistungen die
halten sich an alle regeln die kommen
nicht in berührung mit sanktionen anders
als das hier in der debatte
immer wieder zum ausdruck gebracht wird
und die politische linke und auch bei
den grünen herrscht die argumentation
vor ist seien menschenunwürdig perse zu
sagen zu hören es ist an sich
menschenunwürdig eine sanktion
aussprechen
es gibt aber eine andere seite der
medaille
nicht nur dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht diese
auffassung nicht teilt und da wird auch
schon geurteilt hat das bis zu 30%
sanktionen in deutschland durchaus
zulässig sind und auch mit der
menschenwürde die im grundgesetz
verankert sind zulässig es gibt die
andere seite der medaille nämlich dass
der sozialstaat und die solidarität wir
unterstützen jede der hilfe braucht aber
auch ein gebot der fairness derjenigen
gegenüber ist die diesen sozialstaat
finanzieren dass sie den anspruch an
diejenigen die unterstützten haben
können dass sie alles was in ihrer
möglichkeit besteht
gleichzeitig mit einer starken seite der
förderung auch ihr beitrag leisten
nämlich dass sie termine wahrnehmen wie
wollen wir menschen in einen job
vermittelt bei denen ich für jede
krankschreibung mich auch entschuldigen
muss wo ich morgens pünktlich kommen
will wenn wir nicht die erwartung auch
haben dass leute mit meinen job centern
einen termin wahrnehmen und deswegen war
es uns freie demokraten wichtig dass im
gesamt kompromiss den wir im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben und
das ist ein kennzahl
einer position für sie bedeutet das
immer die koalition die ist zerstritten
für mich bedeutet eine koalition das
unterschiedliche interessen ausgewogen
werden weil es sein spiegelbild
unterschiedlicher interessen in einer
gesellschaft und ist ein kernstück ein
kompromiss zu finden und der kompromiss
doch leider so und der kompromiss dort
eine innere logik und er hat eine innere
logik wird nämlich bis wir das prinzip
von fördern neu justieren setzen wir ein
sanktionsmoratorium ein wo wir aber
weiterhin sagen dieses
sanktionsmoratorium darf nicht zum
kontaktabbruch führen und deswegen haben
wir uns darauf geeinigt dass für termin
verletzung auch weiterhin sanktionen
bestehen und sie eine kleine klasse kann
ich diese frage zu und wir haben uns
ebenfalls darauf geeinigt und das hier
auch ganz deutlich zu machen dass wenn
wir die säule des förderns neu justiert
haben und da haben wir uns als koalition
darauf geeinigt dass beim neuen
bürgerkrieg teilhabe vereinbarungen
haben wo wir auf augenhöhe kommunizieren
sie trotzten auch weiterhin die
erwartung kamen dass man zu terminen
kommt in der vermittlungs vorgang
abgeschafft ist dass man auch
weiterbildungsmaßnahmen durchführen und
deswegen haben wir uns geeinigt dass bei
der neuregelung ist auch weiterhin
abzüge bis zu 30 prozent möglich sind
wenn sie mir nicht glauben dass das das
prinzip von fördern fördern ist gucken
sie in die wirtschaftswoche die hat
heute getötet warum ist warum ist das
bürgergeld ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen leid zitat der grundsatz
fördern und fordern bleibt bestehen
beschäftigen sich in der sache und
machen die konstruktive vorschläge ich
freue mich wenn wir in der anhörung kam
und den ausschuss darüber diskutieren
wir bleiben beim prinzip aber wir gehen
auf die höhe der zeit vielen dank für
den kompromiss und ich freue mich auf
die konstruktive zusammenarbeit
dankeschön
die szene war das sprecher für
bürgergeld das
neue system das sie soll laut
bundesarbeitsministerium bertus heil
noch in diesem jahr möglich sein das ist
eingeführt wird jessica tati sprich
hierzu dienen kennt in die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen also ich frag
mich in der tat wer hier im raum das
gesetz überhaupt gelesen hat sie brechen
mit diesem gesetz ihren
koalitionsvertrag sie haben ein
einjähriges sanktionsmoratorium im
bereich hartz 4 versprochen vor allem
die grünen und die jusos haben sich
dafür feiern lassen und jetzt entpuppt
sich das ganze als mogelpackung hier im
ländle hier im plenum sagte zum beispiel
haben dreizehnter januar mein
geschätzter kollege frank bsirske von
den grünen ich zitiere mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin des weiteren wird im rahmen
eines einjährigen sanktions moratoriums
auf die bisherigen sanktionen verzichtet
etwas anderes ist vom koalitionsvertrag
nicht gedeckt zitat ende auf der
homepage der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen steht bis heute zu lesen bis zu
ihrer gesetzlichen neuregelung setzen
wir die sanktionen aus und was steht
jetzt kurze zeit nach diesem
vollmundigen ankündigungen im gesetz
rund drei viertel aller sanktionen gegen
hartz-iv-empfänger bleiben in kraft
nämlich alle sanktionen für verpasste
termine und meldeversäumnisse aufgesetzt
werden lediglich sanktionen bei
pflichtverletzung verletzung nach § 31
also wenn jemand zum beispiel zu wenige
bewerbungen schreibt und die sollen auch
nicht für ein jahr ausgesetzt werden
sondern nur für sieben monate oder
schlimme daran ist sogar diese
ausgesetzten sanktionen können ab januar
des kommenden jahres nachgeholt werden
so steht es im gesetz
das ist auch wirklich der letzte hier
noch kapiert es gibt überhaupt keinen
sanktionsmoratorium sondern nur eine
zeitliche verzögerung ein aufschieben
von einem mickrigen teil der sanktionen
im januar kommt dann eine sanktion welle
auch die betroffenen zu also da fragt
man sich schon was soll denn dieser mist
zumindest sagen sie die titel des
gesetzes geändert es heißt nicht mehr
sanktionsmoratorium sondern ganz neutral
11 das änderungsgesetz also einen
kleinen letzten rest charme scheinen sie
ja noch im leib zu haben wenn sie die
sanktionen nicht wirklich für ein jahr
stoppen wolle warum haben sie es dann
eigentlich in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
eingeschrieben dieses gesetz ist das
papier nicht wert auf dem es gedruckt
wurde also der passende name während
pinocchio gesetzt schreibt sie wirklich
einhalten wollte was sie den betroffenen
und auch ihren wählern versprochen haben
dann streichen sie doch einfach die
sanktionen aus diesem gesetz sorgen sie
doch lieber mal dafür dass menschen aus
hartz 4 in arbeit kommen dafür dass sie
ihr leben für dich und für ihre familien
mit guter arbeit verbessern können
herzig in minijobs in leiharbeit
befristungen und niedriglöhne zu drängen
nur dass sie dann wieder schnell in
hartz iv landen setzen sie auf dem
sozialen arbeitsmarkt anstatt ihn kaputt
zu sparen auf weiterbildungen auch für
erwerbslose das würde arbeitslosen
abwechslung mal helfen so schaffen sie
nachhaltige perspektiven statt
erwachsenen menschen zu sagen seit graf
oder geht halt hungrig ins bett dieses
gesetz ist eine farce
jessica hatte war das spreche für
arbeitsmarktpolitik ihrer fraktion und
nächste rednerin ist annika klose für
die spd-fraktion sie so zum ausschuss
für arbeit und soziales
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kolleginnen liebe
zuschauer erst einmal ganz kurz zu frau
kathi ich möchte ihnen dazu gute halten
natürlich dass es sich hier um die erste
lesung des gesetzes handelt und sie
dementsprechend den aktuellen
diskussionsstand der koalitionspartner
natürlich nicht kennen können da können
sie auf den ausschuss er kommende woche
man die anhörung gespannt sein ich kann
ihnen aber so viel verraten zwölf monate
sanktionsmoratorium werden kommen und
übrigens auch schon in diesem
gesetzentwurf ist nicht enthalten dass
es um eine ausnahme der sanktionen nach
dem zwölf monaten geht sondern natürlich
handelt es sich da dann also gehen wir
in das neue bürger in geld über und
natürlich werden dann nicht die punkte
aus dieser zeit des moratoriums später
alles hängt also das möchte ich doch
direkter klarstellen ich beim juso
vorsitzende der in berlin des größten
politischen jugendverbands hier in
dieser stadt und habe über jahre daran
mitgewirkt und gekämpft dass wir hier
endlich hinter uns lassen die spd hat
das sind ihre laufwerke zwischenfrage
vom vortag
hat das sind eben sozialstaats kaum
die koordination zwischen fragen nicht
zu dass die spd hat es in dem
sozialstaat konzept 2009/10 eben auch
endlich in ihr programm geschrieben und
ich freue mich dass ich jetzt als
berichterstatterin für eben meine
fraktion hier daran mitwirken kann platz
vier hinter uns zu lassen das neue
bürgergeld einzuführen das ist richtig
und höchste zeit dass die ampel
koalition dieses mammutprojekt endlich
angeht und es ist das richtige projekt
die größte reform des sozialstaats der
letzten zwanzig jahren darauf bin ich
stolz dass wir das angehen da steht
schon vier im koalitionsvertrag drin
aber es ist auch klar es ist viel zu tun
und es gibt auch noch offene fragen mit
einer umfrage wollen wir jetzt
beschäftigen und das sind die
sogenannten mitwirkungspflichten laut
koalitionsvertrag wird es
mitwirkungspflichten auch im neuen
bürger innen geld geben aber sehr
geehrte damen und herren es wäre falsch
die mitwirkungspflichten rein auf die
sanktion zu verkürzen ich möchte
deswegen ein bisschen ausholen geht bei
den bürgern geld eben um ein projekt wo
wir schaffen wollen unseren sozialstaat
an individuum auszurichten wo es um
augenhöhe und vertrauen geht zu stehen
bürger in reduzieren und den
mitarbeiterinnen jobcenter wir wollen
eine teilhabe vereinbarung einführen
statt der eingliederungsvereinbarung die
auf augenhöhe formulierte erarbeitet
werden soll verständlich formuliert und
am ende im konsens abgeschlossen wenn
das nicht passiert ist kein konsens gibt
dann gibt es eine unabhängige
schlichtungsstelle geben damit eben am
ende tatsächlich ein vertrag auf
augenhöhe entsteht wir wollen den
vermittlungs vorrang vorrang abschaffen
das bedeutet dass man eben nicht mehr
jeden x-beliebigen job annehmen muss und
wenn man das nicht tut dann wird man
dafür sanktioniert nein schluss damit es
geht darum was das individuum möchte wo
soll's hingehen welche tätigkeit möchte
meine zukunft aussieht welche branche
welches arbeitsverhältnis welcher umfang
vielleicht auch es ist vielleicht doch
eher eine berufsausbildung eine neue
thema braucht es ist eine weiterbildung
die man angehen möchte all das und
dieser weg für das individuum wird
miteinander auf augenhöhe ausgehandelt
und der gemeinsame weg dahin gefunden
[Applaus]
es geht es um eine kultur auf augenhöhe
aber was ist wenn sich jemand gar nicht
mehr zurück meldet auf dauer nicht
erreichbar ist oder sich die an den
prozess der vereinbart wurde dem
komplett verweigert da sind wir in einem
punkt den wir als gesellschaft neu
diskutieren müssen und das sehen nicht
nur ich sondern das hat auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht uns als
gesetzgeber mit auf den weg gegeben
daher bin ich sehr froh dass wir als
koalition jetzt diesen diese
sanktionsmoratorium mit diesem
sanktionsmoratorium den raum eröffnen um
genau diese debatte nämlich zu führen
und an dieser stelle möchte ich auch
noch mal danke sagen an martin rosemann
dagmar schmidt katja mast und hubertus
heil die eben daran mitgewirkt haben
dass wir dieses moratorium jetzt wirkung
auf den weg bringen können das
moratorium setzt den großteil der
sanktionen für zwölf monate aus und
markiert damit einen klaren bruch
zwischen den alten und den neuen
regelungen ich finde es wichtig denn
gerade die sanktionen haben ja nur zu
einem großteil und einem wichtigen
kritikpunkt an den hartz iv an den hat
sich ihr gesetzen und den regelungen
dort eben geführt einige pflöcke für die
neuen regelungen sind bereits im
koalitionsvertrag verankert erstens
sanktionen auf die kosten der unterkunft
stellen nicht mehr stattfinden zweitens
es wird keine härteren sanktionen für
unter 25-jährige mehr geben sondern da
werden wir mit den trägern der örtlichen
jugendhilfe verstärkt zusammenarbeiten
drittens müssen soll eine sechsmonatige
vertrauens zeit in den ersten sechs
monaten das bürgergeld bezug stattfinden
nach unserer vorstellung ohne sanktionen
viertens so aufsuchende sozialarbeit zum
regelinstrument werden dabei bleibt aber
die frage im raum natürlich warum
eigentlich sanktionen welchen sinn hat
das und wann ist das für uns als
gesellschaft eigentlich gerechtfertigt
leistungen unterhalb des
existenzminimums zu kürzen
bevor man hier über höhe und dauer
dieser neuen regelungen und leistungs
person spricht muss man doch genau diese
fragen diskutiert und geklärt haben
meiner meinung nach kann eine sanktion
wenn wir an diesem instrument festhalten
was wir vereinbart haben
eben immer nur das allerletzte mittel
sein es gibt jobcenter die das genauso
schon praktiziert und die damit sehr
gute erfahrungen machen da geht es
nämlich darum dass man wenn jemand auf
einen brief nicht antwortet eben bei
ankunft und zwar nicht nur einmal
sondern zweimal oder dreimal und wenn
jemand nicht ans telefon geht dann eben
auch mal hingeht sie lachen jetzt aber
sie wissen wissen sie warum wissen sie
warum weil viele menschen die aktuell
dann tatsächlich von sanktionen
betroffen sind die sich vielleicht nicht
zurückmelden das nicht tun weil sie
nicht wollen und sich verweigern sondern
weil sie eben zb unter psychischen
erkrankungen bleiben oder große soziale
probleme haben und das ist genau darum
kennt diese menschen zu unterstützen
diese menschen unterstützen und ihren
kindern zuhören wenn sie kaufen
arbeitsmarkt eigentlich überhaupt nicht
zur verfügung der unterstützung bekommen
müssen und diese genau wo sie ein sachs
würde in frage des kollegen kleinwächter
aus der afd das tue ich nicht den dank
sie sehen die fragen der
mitwirkungspflichten sind doch groß zu
diskutieren und das ist genau der
richtige weg sich dafür die zeit zu
nehmen und diese fragen miteinander zu
beantworten ich freue mich auf die
diskussion und ich freue mich darauf
dass wir eine neue regelung finden die
teilhabe augenhöhe und respekt vor den
sozialen rechten eines reden in den
mittelpunkt stellt vielen dank
annika klose war das hier für die spd
fraktion hat hier auch spontan noch auf
lacher aus dem plenum reagiert es gibt
aber eine kurze intervention von der
linken jessica text danke frau
präsidentin dass sie die zwischen
intervention zu lassen es ist nicht so
dass mit einem gesetz der mit einem
gesetz was eingebracht wird das
komplette sgb 2 vergessen werden kann
und im sgb 2 steht ja mehr gerade
widersprochen dass die sanktionen nicht
nachgeholt werden können im sgb 2 steht
in paragraf 31 b absatz 1 satz 5 sgb 2
gerne nachlesen dass eine sanktion
innerhalb von sechs monaten ab dem
zeitpunkt der pflichtverletzung zu
erfolgen hat und dieser paragraph bleibt
die ganze zeit in kraft und deshalb ist
es so dass die menschen nicht davor
geschützt sind dass sie trotz ihres
gesetzes dann sanktioniert werden und
wenn sie mir da nicht widersprechen
dann werden frage ob sie sicher zu
sichern können jetzt zu sichern können
dass das in der nachbesserung ihres
gesetzes drin ist sie können auch nicht
sich beschweren dass die opposition
kritik äußert wir bearbeiten den
gesetzentwurf der uns vorliegt
sie reagieren
fazit
sehr geehrte frau kathi ich möchte das
auch nicht kritisieren dass er sich auf
den vorliegenden gesetzesentwurf
beziehen das habe ich auch zu beginn
seiner rede gesagt sondern dass es ja
eben eine diskussion statt in der
koalition gibt und wir nächste woche ja
hoffentlich wieder darüber diskutiert
werden müssen und die änderungsanträge
im ausschuss vorliegen werden wir haben
diese themen auf dem schirm wir haben
sie auch schon miteinander gesprochen
und es ist so dass wir festgehalten
haben das eben keine spätere
sanktionierung dieser verstöße daneben
stattfinden soll das geht auch
überweisungen an die jobcenter umsetzung
anweisungen aber wir nehmen wir haben
den punkt auf den schirm und
und das steht in der begründung also ja
das heißt da kann das kann ich ihnen
zusichern dass das so wollte
soweit also die kurzintervention und
erwiderung von links und spd fraktion
wir verlassen heute die debatte hier das
thema sanktionen bei hartz 4
beziehungsweise arbeitslosengeld 2 wird
uns natürlich noch weiter beschäftigen
auch weil das hier ist die erste lesung
war also dass ich auch noch mal in den
plenarsaal kommt nächste woche gibt es
wieder eine sitzungswoche auch dann
werden wir natürlich darüber berichten
unter anderem mit einer
regierungserklärung zum
ausserordentlichen europäischen rat der
ansteht jetzt gebe ich aber erst einmal
für weitere informationen zu meiner
kollegin ab zu ines arland